delivering it over to high he finds an open Leon
dry Cy cross ice pass kulak is in driving to the
net kulak shoots def to the save rebound cleared
away a centering pass it went through everybody
hot trickles through Conor Brown Now using
that forced to get the puck out as McDavid
enters the Zone drops it back Brown the shot
def go the save and he Sops Kan on the rebound
julson getting that puck over to Connor Garland
he realizes he has some space hands it off to
peton back to Garland and what a beautiful goal
for Conor [Applause] [Music] Garland the first
goal of the season for the Vancouver Canucks
off the Stick of Conor Garland and a lot of
talk about him talking to other organizations
and having that permission Elliot freem with a
great conversation about that but he just
put it to rest he talked about preparing
for this game coming out playing his best
no matter what goes on says he didn't ask
for a trade and puts a beautiful move on this
bouncing Puck that gets by Brett kulak it's a
lob little bouncer it finds it right on the
stick and quick hands in tight by Garland on
the four check almost creating another
good opportunity right in tight for the
con the Oilers started off to the pass here
picked off Garland pass in front Campbell
he's able to get a hold of it and he hangs on
Fifth NHL season for Quinn Hughes as Bard now
racing to the p d ji there as well JT Miller
pouncing on it finds bisser the shot and he
scores and just like that the Canucks are off and
running it's two to nothing from Vancouver this
season renewed wanting to get back to a great
start and this is how you do it you come out
excellent for check by the Canucks here DJ seppi
this line combination's been together all training
camp for the Vancouver Canucks DJ SEI to Miller
beautiful little backhand pass this is skill
right here little quiet spot besser left alone
and he did not take that much time to get that
shot away two nothing Canucks what a shot not much
space out there Hughes to JT Miller and the Canuck
quickly back on the attack here is Myers winds
up fires Campell to save rebound D de SEI was
there they were working out those Kinks but it
still is a work in progress and meanwhile the
Vancouver Canucks often running with a two nothing
lead here now at the start of this second period
Evan Bard controlling for Edmonton gradually
moving up ice getting his stick on that puck
was p advancing to McDavid he shot dico is there
and pman who's trying to force it in at the it's
fair to say they won their share in the first
period and such a focus on the fitness aspect
as well which is something you you know firsthand
about Rick talking you and him have spend some
time in the gym together here's Herona coming
in with a wrist of rebound Jack Campell made
the initial save with the connect [Applause]
[Music] score and it finds its way in C trying
to deny it a second time it's the patient play
of B great backhand feed the first opportunity
on the rebound gets jammed towards the net and
then besser just Waits first chance right there
it's Miller that has the first whack at it and
watch this out of the air besser just kind of
TAPS it through and unable to capitalize on
the power play that they haven't needed it
with three even strength goals thus far Pon
from way up top connects with Hughes over to
Miller the shot CLE the save but the rebound
besser accepts the pass gets it over to Hughes
back to besser besser now gives it over to Pon
moving it to Kangle Pon has it again from the
corner Elias Pon and that pu trickles into
the net Brock besser hatrick for Z for the
kxs let let's take another look at this goal
and there it is there and you can see Jack
Campell that slow motion he's already reading Far
Side coming out to take down where Miller would
be who is going to be the recipient of this
Puck goes off the toe I believe a besser and
boom Finds Its way in the net he still had the
wherewithal Campbell to get that pat down and
try and stop it but so hard to change your mind
once your mid movement across from post to post
and it finds its way through for a 4 nothing lead
and Brock besser with the hattrick and for Jack
Campell who who had allowed only three goal
shorten the deficit on this Power Play here's
McDavid onetime from buard he didn't get proper
wood on that D was looking to cover up that puck
another opportunity Bard back to McDavid McDavid
Down Low onetime Dry CLE shoots and scores and
there's that power play marker for the Oilers so
I looked at the bench as soon as that penalty was
taken and they didn't like it too much of some
shaking heads get your feet moving backtrack
and lesson learned as the power play goes to
work you give them chances give them looks and
eventually they're going to make you pay it's
Leon dry CLE beautiful pass by McDavid takes
the middle of the ice goes back out almost
on the goal line for dry cital so hard for a
goenda back to pon pon finds Quinn Hughes Hughes
more of a shot mentality from him in the preseason
here's a shot p finds the twine and it's 5 to
one for the [Music] Canucks and this time it's
Pon good movement around here for Quinn Hughes
goes down to the half wall typically where Pon
would be he feels in the position where Hughes
usually is and Zips that rer through the traffic
H up the whole time and once he finds that lane
a d speaking of the Oilers bottom six it's Jay
Woodcraft sending McLoud full and hallway out
there as they've looked pretty good no question
you stop it here's Hughes with a shot towards
the net and Brock besser has four tonight in
the Canuck season [Music] opener in the right
spot at the right time you want to score goals
in this league it's never a bad idea to get to
the N you can see broberg has him and then he
just kind of flares around him as two guys taking
one in front it's JT Miller double teamed but that
leaves Brock Bessler open goes off the shin pad
of Evan buard up for tonight and almost had five
there kzo tried to feather that pass through P
standing right at the top of the crease right
through here's JT Miller the rer and it's in
the [Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] net
touchdown for the kucks It's s to one to the pon
goal use the shot through the screen very willing
to get shots through and you can see de har trying
to get into a shooting Lane and blocker you've got
besser in front but look at the flexing that
stick on the wrer far side off the baring in
and look at this view steuart Skinner's a big
guy he's looking around once that shot here's
Heros now to Myers quickly up the wall and on the
attack again is Sam laery coming in with speed a
pass over to Josh [Applause] [Music] scar conu
continuing to add to this lead it is 8 to one
here in the third period that he denies and on
the ensuing play it's just a puck battle one and
give lafy some credit here the Speedy McLoud can't
track him down and he just fights his way through
that check and is able to force this Puck over
one shot at it and then the second opportunity
the first one kind of bobbles through and Dakota
Joshua bangs that one home at the end 11 goals
last year he gets on the board just drive to that
blue paint win the stick battle dime seconds here
as the Canucks faithful get set to celebrate the
first victory of the [Applause] [Music] season h